st louis is how we're going to start
today they're marking the student team
holiday by dedicating a memorial to an
important and often forgotten chapter of
american history it involves dred scott
the key figure in infamous supreme court
case scott was an enslaved man who
claimed that he and his family should be
freed because they had lived for a time
in a free state he sued under a missouri
law and he won leading to an 11-year
legal battle in 1857 the supreme court
threw out that verdict a decision that
helped put the north and south on a
collision course towards civil war now
here's something i bet you didn't know
we certainly didn't scott was not the
only person to file a freedom suit chris
van cleave met a judge descended from
slavery who fought for years to
establish a memorial to them
the sound of history being remembered
a story of freedom fighters being
honored
cast in more than 8 thousand pounds of
bronze and standing nearly two stories
tall
this monument's installation in front of
the saint louis civil courts building is
the emotional end to a story that began
two centuries ago missouri law held if a
person was once free they were always
free it allowed slaves like dredd and
harriet scott to sue for their freedom
the scott's story spelled out in these
handwritten affidavits convinced an
all-white jury to free them this was
really based on
family preservation lynn jackson is
their great great granddaughter they
were there to save their daughters they
hid them away
for possibly up to two years just to
keep them from being sold during this
process for about 20 years there was
sort of a golden age of slave freedom
suits historian kenneth nguyen was the
missouri state archivist when a court
clerk made a startling discovery the
scots were not alone buried in old court
records and lost to history until the
late 1990s were at least 306 so-called
freedom suits brought by slaves in saint
louis seeking their freedom wynn
estimates more than 120 cases were
successful it shows the collective
effort of a people trying to be free who
did not rest and just accept their lot
in slavery but resisted it it really
speaks in some ways to people who
believed in the integrity of the law
tucked inside this case file from 1821
the jury's findings hand written by its
foreman
we all the jurors find that the
plaintiff is free
this is something that saint louis
should honor you had to be pretty brave
and courageous just to file the suit
because if you lost the consequences
could be dire circuit court judge david
mason a descendant of slaves spent the
last 14 years pushing for a freedom suit
memorial its installation brought him to
tears
when i'm reading these files
and reading the affidavits of the slaves
i mean i'm hearing them
i'm feeling them i'm hearing
my people
these were some of the strongest people
over 500 years
that have ever been produced in american
society these freedom suits were hard
fought legal victories remember it's the
middle of the 1800s so a slave walking
into a st louis courtroom wasn't allowed
to read or write couldn't even testify
in a court of law the judge and jury
consisted solely of white men and
missouri was a slave state here's a time
when the jury was likely biased against
yes
against the person suing for their
freedom the judge was likely biased in
some ways against them and that they
still the system still worked yes what
does that say about
justice
that means that it can work
truth is powerful
facts are powerful
having the strength to look
falsehood in the eye and call it out for
what it is
is powerful funded by private donations
the towering sculpture entitled
freedom's home is set to be officially
unveiled as the nation celebrates
juneteenth
the names of all 330 known freedom suit
plaintiffs will be added around its base
what do you think dredd and harriet
would say
they would be happy and they would be
proud but they would totally feel like
they did not deserve all of this
recognition a piece of american history
once largely lost
well worth recognizing
and remembering for cbs mornings i'm
chris van cleave in st louis
nicely done chris van cleef talk about
an uphill battle yeah they persisted and
persevered and the courage involved in
that day and age because if you lose
it's a real bad scene it already is yeah
you speak on the odds being stacked
against you you walk into a courtroom
you're not supposed to be able to read
or write
a courtroom full of all white men in a
slave state but like he said the truth
is powerful yeah powerful yeah you're
not even viewed as a human being back
yeah about that